moi j'ai vraiment envie que ce spectacle
porte une notion d'espoir et une sonde
joie de vivre et de joie de vivre en
commun en fait façon collectif et qu'on
ne peut pas avancer sans loi fournit
obligé d'avancer avec l'autre
[Musique]
on a une sono graphique est vraiment
particulière il y à des rails qui sont
posés au sol qui font le lit mètres de
diamètre et il y adeux le cube motorisés
sur ses rails
ces pubs en fait les danseurs vont
tourner tout temps quasiment que durant
le long du spectacle
et puis vont essayer de trouver leur
équilibre
le jeu avec l'autre et puis ensuite le
déséquilibre pour qu' il ya une question
en fait qui domine dans ce spectacle
c'est si je tombe
est ce que tu es là pour moi forcément
ça commence assez lentement puis avec le
jeu avec l'interprétation
ça va de plus en plus vite donc du coup
le danger
le risque est de plus en plus grands
c'est quelque chose aussi combat on
partage avec le public puisqu'il ya un
moment donné dans le spectacle qu'ils
vont être au milieu alors avec les
règles sanitaires actuelles sans toucher
le public mais en tout cas il est pris à
partie il est pris dans le jeu pour
aller un peu plus loin et dans leurs
relations et dans la question de
l'interactivité